PAUL STARES: OK, let's -- is this on?
Yeah, let's get started.
Welcome, everybody, to this special roundtable
on "Saudi Arabia in the New Middle East."
Thank you all for coming here.
I'm sure many of you would prefer to be in
Davos at the moment, but we will try to do
our best and compensate for that.
The focus today is obviously Saudi Arabia.
And I think it's fair to say that there are
few countries more important to the global
economy than Saudi Arabia.
And I think it's also fair to say that there
are few countries have been a more steadfast
ally to the United States in the Middle East
for the last six decades.
But for all of that importance, I think it's
quite remarkable, even shocking, how little
we still know about the kingdom.
There are very few true experts on Saudi Arabia
in the United States, and we're very pleased
to have two of them here today to talk about
Saudi Arabia.
We're going to be focusing on several, obviously,
I think, relevant -- currently relevant issues
relating to Saudi Arabia; firstly, the -- you
know, what's been happening inside the kingdom
since the onset of the Arab upheavals; how
this has been received in the kingdom, how
they've been adapting, what their new posture
in the Middle East has been since the uprisings
began; and then finally what this all bodes
for the future of the U.S. relationship with
the kingdom.
We will begin first with Gregory Gause.
He is a professor political science of the
University of Vermont.
He has held multiple positions before joining
the faculty there.
He is the author of three books, most recently,
"The International Relations of the Persian
Gulf," and, I should say, most importantly,
this most -- this council special report that's
just come out on "Saudi Arabia in the New
Middle East."
And there should be rare unsigned copies on
your seats.
That's for you to take home with you.
He will talk for about 20 minutes or so, 15,
20 minutes, and then will be followed by Toby
Jones, who is at the History Department at
Rutgers University.
Toby has also held several academic positions
before joining Rutgers and from 2004 to 2006
was with the International Crisis Group in
the Persian Gulf.
He, too, is the author of a book focusing
on Saudi Arabia, "Desert Kingdom: How Oil
and Water Forged Modern Saudi Arabia."
So I think we will begin.
I should just say -- mention the ground rules.
The discussion today is on the record, unlike
usual council policy.
And I also ask you to turn off any cell phones,
other devices, defibrillators excepted, and
we will begin.
So Greg, take it away.
>>F. GREGORY GAUSE: Thanks very much, Paul.
Am I on here?
>>STARES: Yeah.
>>GAUSE: All right.
Thanks everybody for coming.
If you're disappointed that you didn't get
invited to Davos, come on up to Vermont; we've
got mountains, we've got a little bit of snow
this season -- not as much as usual, but we
can recreate the Davos experience for you,
and you can get some maple syrup while you're
there.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I want to thank Paul and the council for allowing
me to write this.
I think I stretch Paul's patience on numerous
occasions.
He runs the Center for Preventive Action,
and I kind of am an advocate of what I would
call "prudent nonaction" in the Middle East.
And so he was very tolerant of me on this.
Let me just say a couple of words about these
three topics that Paul introduced.
One is the internal dynamics within the country.
My bottom line is that I think this is a very
stable country in terms of regime stability,
the political stability of the regime.
We have, I think, in the United States a tendency
when we see upheavals in the Middle East to
automatically assume that Saudi Arabia is
going to be next.
I think that's largely because they're a monarchy,
and we don't understand or appreciate monarchies,
having gotten rid of one ourselves some years
ago.
Sorry about that, Paul, but -- (laughter)
-- and because, I think, they wear funny clothes.
And so we just think that they must be on
the verge.
But I think the regime is quite remarkable
in how it has weathered the various storms
that it has faced in the modern Middle East.
So how does it do it?
Particularly, how did it do it this time?
I think that there are three important things
to highlight, and the most important and obvious
one is money.
Right?
Not a single oil regime fell of its own accord
in the Arab Spring.
All right?
Libya had -- required Western military intervention
to remove that regime.
No other oil regime fell in the Arab Spring,
and very few oil regimes even faced serious
upheaval, Libya being the most notable exception,
which just goes to show that the money doesn't
spend itself.
Right?
And if you have an idiot spending the money
or not spending the money, the money doesn't
do any good.
Right?
But it's not just monarchies.
It's Algeria, Iraq.
These places did not have the same kinds of
problems that many of their neighbors had.
So with oil at a hundred -- over a hundred
dollars a barrel, that gives regimes quite
a few carrots and sticks to deal with restive
populations.
The second reason I think that the Saudis
weathered this is their networks, and money
is part of this, but the political skill of
maintaining networks is something that is
the best of the al-Saud family.
They portion this out.
They have portfolios for various princes to
deal with various groups.
They have networks with the business community.
They have networks with the -- with the tribes,
which are socially important but politically,
I would argue, almost completely emasculated.
And that has been -- a project of the al-Saud
family is to keep -- is to -- is to destroy
tribal political power.
With Shi'a leaders, with regional leaders
in the Hejaz, with intellectuals, with every
group that you can imagine, sports clubs,
the al-Saud family has its networks here,
and it activated all of those networks during
this year.
And finally, I think that one of the most
important things that distinguishes cases
in the Arab world where the regime feel from
cases where the regime is still holding on
or didn't suffer any crisis at all is the
ability of the opposition to overcome its
own internal ideological and social, sectarian,
ethnic -- whatever you want to call them -- social
differences, and unite behind a common -- a
common goal of getting rid of the regime.
In Saudi Arabia, the opposition has never
been able to do that, and the opposition is
divided on sectarian lines; it is divided
on ideological lines.
Even during the upheavals of earlier this
year, those who were looking for political
change in Saudi Arabia had to put together
two major petitions, not one, because they
couldn't agree to get together on one petition.
If you can't agree to get together on one
petition, you're certainly not going to overthrow
a regime, it seems to me.
That doesn't mean that the Saudis are out
of the woods.
They do have some medium-term issues.
Obviously, the succession issue is one that
we as outsiders have very, very little insight
into, but it is a serious problem for the
regime.
And I don't mean from King Abdullah to Prince
Nayef.
I mean from this current generation of rulers
to the next generation, to the grandsons of
the founding kind of the third kingdom.
That is a -- that is a transition that has
no precedent and will be a very interesting
thing to watch.
But it's not going to happen this year or
next.
Fiscal issues -- all right?
Just the other day, Ali Naimi said that a
hundred dollars a barrel is what the Saudis'
price goal is.
Toby and I were talking before lunch.
We can -- we're not that old.
He's even younger than I am.
But we can remember when the price point was
$28 a barrel, and it wasn't that long ago.
All right?
A hundred dollars a barrel -- that means that
the Saudis need that money -- paying these
networks to maintain the system, and thus,
I think that -- although I'm no -- I wouldn't
even claim that I could protect the oil markets;
I would -- I would not be a penurious academic
if I could predict the oil markets -- we don't
know if oil's going to be a hundred dollars
a barrel or $110 for the next five or six
years.
Who knows?
A fiscal squeeze, if oil goes down below $80
a barrel or $70 a barrel, would be a very
interesting challenge for the Saudis.
Finally, I think that -- one of the things
-- to me the most interesting thing that's
happened this year, this past year, in the
Middle East is I think that -- I mean, Fukuyama's
"End of History" finally came to the Middle
East.
Right?
And I think just at a time when Fukuyama has
backed away from "End of History," I actually
think the thesis is more powerful than ever.
Right?
I think that the events in the Middle East
this past year have basically said that there
is no defensible political system that doesn't
have a democratic element to it.
That doesn't mean that we're going to have
democracy and that doesn't mean people aren't
going to push against it.
And one of the reasons I say this is because
of the reaction of Salafi Islamists to this
-- to the events of the past year.
Right?
I'm no fan of the Salafis, even though I spent
some time in Riyadh.
And I was troubled by their -- what a significant
portion of the vote they got in Egypt.
But if one steps back and says, this was the
element of Islamist politics that had been
explicitly anti-democratic, that had said
on doctrinal grounds that democracy is rejected;
it's an innovation; it's un-Islamic; we don't
need it -- and now not only do we see Salafis
participating in the electoral process in
Egypt, but we see Salafi figures in Saudi
Arabia signing petitions calling for an elected
national legislature.
We see Salafi figures in Saudi Arabia publicly
praising the Egyptian revolution and supporting
it.
This is something that I think in the -- in
the longer term will have to trouble the Saudi
regime, because it has always based its right
to rule on the idea that it represents the
true Islam, right, this Salafist strain of
Islam.
And in the end, it seems to me that coming
out of 2011, one of the important turns is
that the only people who now argue that there
are bases other than some form of popular
consent upon which to base regimes are the
official clergy in Saudi Arabia, the proponents
of Velayat-e faqih in Iran, and al Qaeda.
And that doesn't seem to be a winning team
in the future.
I'm not predicting waves of democracy in the
future.
I see >>MR.
Abrams in the back.
I'm still not on the team.
But I do think that -- I do think that this
has been a major shift that will have long-term
consequences for Saudi Arabia and the region.
OK, regionally, briefly, I don't see Saudi
Arabia as counterrevolutionary.
I think that that's too easy a trope.
And my friend Toby Jones will tell me why
I'm wrong in a minute, but let me set out
why.
I think that Saudi Arabia's clearly counterrevolutionary
when it comes to monarchy.
It sees monarchy as absolutely essential.
It sees the preservation of monarchy, particularly
in its geographical area, the Gulf -- and
we'll include Jordan in that -- as absolutely
essential to its own domestic regime security
and stability.
And thus for Saudi Arabia, the preservation
of monarchy in the Gulf Cooperation Council
and in Jordan is a domestic political imperative.
However, once we get beyond that, it seems
to that what Saudi Arabia -- the lens through
which Saudi Arabia is looking at the Arab
-- the events of 2011 is through its regional
competition with Iran.
And thus it's more than willing to support
regime change in a place like Syria.
It was willing to support regime change, obviously,
in Libya -- but that was, I think, more because
of the distinctive characteristics of the
brother leader and his past history with Saudi
Arabia -- and was willing, however reluctantly
and however cautiously and non-democratically
-- very happy to admit that -- to ease or
try to ease Ali Abdullah Saleh out of power
in Yemen.
So to me, that's not counterrevolutionary.
That's a country that's confused, defensive
and basically looking through -- looking at
the region through the prism of a political
competition with Iran.
Finally, the American agenda -- I stole the
word "transactional," which if you looked
at the pamphlet, is the kind of keyword for
the -- my recommendations for the U.S.-Saudi
relationship.
I stole that from the irrepressible Chas Freeman,
who was the chairman of our advisory group.
But I do think it captures something important
in that the relationship with Saudi Arabia
is -- has been going through a slow-motion
change since the end of the Cold War, really
since the 1970s, I would say, when the Saudis
in effect took over their old -- their own
oil industry.
The two great pillars historically of American-Saudi
cooperation were Saudi operation of -- I mean,
American operation of the Saudi oil industry
and a common Cold War understanding of the
globe.
And that doesn't mean we agreed on everything
-- oil embargo in 1973.
Right?
But those two pillars are no longer.
We have numerous common interests geopolitically
in the region, but I don't think that we can
assume that the Saudis are going to be with
us on everything the way they were in the
'80s, when we were partners in all sorts of
anti-Soviet activities.
I don't think that the Saudis should assume
that we'll always be with them.
I think we have to take it issue by issue.
I think that one of the dynamics that is becoming
increasingly apparent is that Saudi Arabia
is no longer an oil moderate; it's no longer
a dove in the oil market.
It doesn't play the role that it seemed to
-- that it played in the '80s and '90s.
It's always been more complicated than that.
But when Ali Naimi, the oil minister, says
the other day that the target price for Saudi
Arabia for oil is a hundred dollars a barrel,
that's not what I would call a price moderate.
So I think that on those issues, the assumption
-- as we're entering an election year, American
presidents like to call Saudi kings during
election years and say, hey, do something
about those oil prices.
I'm not sure that that kind of thing is going
to fly anymore.
Two issues that I think are extremely important
in which we have common interests but also
different viewpoints that are going to require
a lot of conversation with the Saudis: One
is the rise of sectarianism in the politics
of the Arab East.
This is Bahrain.
This is Iraq.
This is Syria.
This is -- North Africa, thank God, is immune
to this because of its own demographic profile,
but the Arab East is riven with sectarianism
now.
Sectarianism is not a new thing, but its salience
rises and falls over time, and it's extremely
high right now.
And Saudi Arabia is pushing it.
One of the reasons that sectarianism is so
salient now is Saudi Arabia's chosen to play
that card.
I think that that's very dangerous for American
interests.
Sectarian -- this atmosphere of sectarian
hospitality is a breeding ground for Sunni
radicalism of the al Qaeda variety.
I also think that it's very negative in terms
of the future of Iraq.
I think that if there's a practical policy
issue here -- I think getting the Saudis to
engage with the Iraqi government, as distasteful
as they find that government, is an imperative.
And I also think it's self-defeating because,
you know, frankly, you push -- you know, Arab
Sh'ia are not particularly important, except
in the Gulf region and Lebanon.
Right?
And to the extent that sectarianism dominates
politics, that drives them toward Iran.
Framing things in an Arab-versus-Persian context
can actually help bring these folks in.
And I know that there are people in Saudi
Arabia who are troubled by this, too, and
see this as a difficult problem.
And finally, the nuclear question: I think
that there are very strong incentives among
Saudi leaders that if Iran were to cross the
nuclear threshold, however we define that
crossing, then there would be enormous support
within the Saudi elite for trying to obtain
their own nuclear weapons.
I don't think that's inevitable.
I think a lot depends on their relationship
with us, but I think that that's a conversation
we have to start having with them, because
I think that if that happens, if they come
to an understanding that Iran is now a nuclear
power, however they define that -- and I understand
that that's a complicated question -- then
things could move very quickly and uncharacteristically
for the Saudis.
I think things could move very quickly on
their side, and I think that that's a conversation
that's worth having with them right now.
Thanks, Paul.
>>STARES: Great.
Thanks very much, Greg.
Toby?
>>TOBY JONES: Thanks, also, to Paul and the
council for bringing me down.
I'm an unenviable position, because I'm pressed
to respond or charged with the responsibility
of responding with somebody on key points
that I agree with.
So it's sort of hard, in one sense, to kind
of point to what I think are critical weaknesses
or points in divergence in Greg's -- you know,
this excellent report.
But I do think there are places where there
are opportunities for at least considering
if not more nuance at least more uncertainty.
Where I'm not -- it's not quite as clear to
me that things will move in a direction or
have moved in a direction that necessarily
point to either stability or the indefinite
necessity of maintaining a strong relationship
-- for the Americans to maintain a strong
relationship with Saudi Arabia.
So I'm going to speak on two sets of issues,
both of which Greg raised in his report and
that he spoke about today.
And I'm going to, on the first one, suggest
an alternative viewpoint on Saudi Arabia's
stability and where it may or may not go in
the short to medium term.
I'll offer this as a sort of preliminary comment
for the kind of analytical view that I'll
offer up in just a few moments.
Past stability is no predictability of future
stability.
I'm a historian and so I don't predict the
future.
But boy, if the Arab Spring taught historians
anything, it's that autocratic Arab regimes
are not stable and that long-standing claims
that these were durable political systems
surely hasn't weathered 2011.
And we have to think about the various possibilities
for places like Saudi Arabia, oil producers
and others, who have yet to experience the
kind of political mobilization and mass uprising
and ask the question, are they in fact vulnerable
to the sorts of shocks that brought down regimes
elsewhere, whether it's a combination of domestic
or external forces that bring them down.
The second issue and set of questions that
-- second set of issues that I want to touch
on is, I want to sort of encourage a more
critical and perhaps revisionist view of the
U.S.-Saudi relationship not necessarily historically
but grounded in more recent events, and the
role that Saudi Arabia -- and to sort of encourage
thinking about the role that Saudi Arabia
actually plays in the Middle East, and the
way that the United States has talked about
its interests and raised the question.
Are they actually the same?
And I don't think they are.
So on the first set of issues, who no -- which
I think can be boiled down to this question:
Why was there no Arab Spring in Saudi Arabia?
Or more directly in response to Greg's report,
was Saudi Arabia in fact little affected by
the events of 2011?
It's true that there were no street protests
of any consequence, the regime was not toppled,
nor was it ever seriously threatened by the
kind of social and political mobilization
that took place elsewhere.
But I want to suggest that in fact if you
revisit the events of early 2011, a period
of great uncertainty in the region, when friendly
regimes were falling from power, Mubarak most
notably, but not only Mubarak.
It also was important to recall that the first
indications of uprisings in Yemen, Bahrain
and Syria also first materialized in February
and early March, that Saudi Arabia was deeply
anxious and certain about what its own political
future was vis-a-vis its regional neighbors.
And in fact, it in responded with alarm.
I had a piece that appeared at Foreign Policy
that made the case that there was a deep sense
of anxiety that had settled in over Riyadh
and that they were acting with some sense
of desperation and trying to both preempt
mobilization at home, as well as to figure
out what was going on in the rest of the region.
And yes, I was one of the early proponents
of Saudi Arabia as a counterrevolutionary
force.
I'll come back to that, thinking regionally.
But I think just as important is, how did
Saudi Arabia handle its domestic affairs,
and why was there no mass political mobilization?
Greg outlined what I think are the key points
in terms of its instrumental approach to dealing
with domestic crisis and the possibility of
political ferment: money, patronage, the mobilization
of Islam in important ways, and also the ways
it moved Saudi domestic pieces on the chessboard.
The al-Saud have historically demonstrated
nothing if they're not masters of dividing
and pitting various domestic constituencies
against one another.
But it's also important to note that it was
no guarantee that this was going to work.
And I'll come back to how I think this actually
played out in important ways -- that in fact
Saudi Arabia is an incredibly diverse place.
It's diverse religiously, culturally, politically,
geographically, ethnically -- well, maybe
not ethnically, but, you know, let's not push
it too far.
I mean, so -- but you know, this is a large
place, and it's controlled by a group of political
elites that have often understood that they
are sort of presented with the challenge of
dealing with and managing a society and a
population that often sees itself at odds
with their political masters.
And don't be fooled by the absence of kind
of public declarations of disillusion with
the Saudi regime.
There is a deep sense of frustration in Saudi
Arabia with political corruption, with the
absence of political possibility, with the
nature of autocracy at home and all of the
excess that it means.
These have been long-standing concerns amongst
important sectors of the Saudi population.
From the late 1970s, we've seen episodes of
political dissent at home that, sure, of course,
it hasn't materialized in a widespread revolutionary
movement, but that nevertheless has been persistent
over the last three or four decades.
The reason that Saudi dissidents, not only
the opposition but other political forces,
have not been able to mobilize or come together
in any meaningful way is not indication of
the absence of the political will to do so.
I think it comes down to two things.
One is that the state has tremendous coercive
power.
Greg mentioned in the report the power of
its security forces.
It's important to note that in early March
the Saudis deployed thousands of police forces
to preempt the day of rage that was called
for.
If I'm a Saudi and I live in Riyadh -- and
Riyadh doesn't have the kind of public sphere
that Cairo has -- where am I going to converge?
Where is that public space where we can make
a united, you know, sort of demand, or call
on political reform?
There isn't one.
I mean, Riyadh is sort of mapped out and laid
out much like Chicago.
It's a big grid, except for the old city.
There are no obvious places for people to
mobilize.
Double that or couple that with the presence
of a large number of security forces.
Of course there was no day of rage in Saudi
Arabia.
If Saudis needed any indication of how they
would have been treated, they could have easily
imagined a Syria-like scenario unfolding or
a Bahrain-like scenario unfolding to keep
them from doing so.
Right?
So there was a powerful security apparatus
and disincentives for people to take to the
public square, and there was a limited public
square to take to in the first place.
The other -- and I think this is much more
important in some ways, speaking to both Saudi
Arabia's political strategy, as well as the
legacy of a certain a kind of politics that
has gripped the country or that has guided
the country over the last three, four decades,
and that is the various ways that Saudi Arabia's
leaders have mobilized both Islam and culture
in order to accomplish short-term political
goals.
If you think of who the two most restive groups
in Saudi Arabia were in 2011, it was Shi'ites,
and it was women -- troubled communities,
unlikely revolutionaries and certainly unlikely
to capture the attention of tens of thousands
or even millions of their fellow citizens.
Women's issues are polarizing in Saudi Arabia.
They mobilize people in support of women as
much as they mobilize people in opposition
to women's rights.
The question of gender and gender relations
is highly charged and problematic, and the
Saudi state understands this.
And when it can put women rather than political
reform or constitutional monarchy or equal
rights or participation at the center of analysis
in political discourse, it knows it's got
a winning strategy.
The same thing is true when it comes to sectarianism
and Shi'ites.
Greg mentioned that Saudi Arabia is in many
ways problematic in the way that it plays
the sectarian card.
I mean, it's important to know.
Shi'ites are a minority in Saudi Arabia.
Perhaps they make up 10, 15 percent of the
population.
That's a pretty significant number of folks
-- a million, a million and a half, maybe
at the outside 2 million people.
When they became active in March -- late February,
early March 2011, the regime rushed in very
quickly to mobilize on this moment and to
use their activism as a way to discredit other
potential civic or civil disobedience or public
dissent.
So the state then plays upon both the question
of women and religious difference as a way
to divide society.
Greg mentioned sort of the division -- sort
of divide-and-conquer mentality and approach
to domestic politics that has long characterized
Saudi Arabia's approach to its own citizens.
This was on fully display earlier this year,
and it's incredibly effective.
Saudi Arabia has a highly atomized society
in which people don't necessarily identify
with one another across gender or class or
sectarian lines, religious lines.
And so I think to a large extent, the state's
ability to play upon these, manipulate them
and fan the flames of uncertainty about Shi'ism,
as well as to use women as a wedge issue,
also explained a kind of political paralysis
that didn't necessarily displace the importance
of concerns about political -- about corruption
and reform and all those other things, at
least not permanently, but managed to do so
in the short term.
On the second question, was Saudi Arabia a
little affected?
I actually don't agree with this.
I think that Saudi Arabia was deeply affected
by the events of 2011.
And if we look at the way that Abdullah managed
the issues in March, we see an important recalibration
of Saudi domestic politics and the various
political forces that are often at play there.
Most importantly was not the spending of money,
was not necessarily the mobilization of certain
patronage networks.
It's how the money was spent.
Abdullah announced what would amount to a
$140 billion bailout package for Saudi institutions
and citizens in March as a way to preempt,
and bonuses to public employees -- convinced
businessmen to give similar kinds of bonuses
to those in the private sector.
But most importantly was the redistribution
in intensified fashion of money to religious
institutions, accommodating not only institutions
like the religious police but as well as others
-- talking about tens of millions of dollars
being re-funneled into old Islamist networks
that had enjoyed some favor in the 1980s and
early 1990s but that had increasingly come
under pressure in the leadership of Abdullah.
If we think about Saudi Arabia's modern history
as characterized in phases, its most important
modern moment was 1979.
Events in the region, as well as events at
home, put the al-Saud under tremendous pressure.
Particularly one moment in November, when
Sunni radicals seized Mecca mosque, the state
was put in a defensive position where it felt
like it had to accommodate Islamists in order
to preempt any kind of Islamist revolution.
Over the course of the 1980s and early 1990s,
this meant moving money out of development
projects and other kinds of consumer projects
and into Islamist networks and projects -- jihad
in Afghanistan but also the support for charitable
and other kinds of intellectual and religious
networks at home.
The result was that by the end of the 1980s,
there were hundreds of thousands of Saudi
men who had been educated and trained in the
Islamic arts, in the Islamic sciences, to
the detriment of things like business and
more technical fields.
But it also meant the politicization of Islam
in important ways.
Saudi Arabia is fully realized, I think, as
an Islamic state only in the 1980s and early
1990s.
When Abdullah became king in 2005, he initially
took several bold measures in order to undo
that arrangement.
He announced that Islamic law in the courts
would be codified; they'd be systematized
under the direct leadership of the state.
He made high-profile decisions about personnel,
on the Supreme Islamic Council, as well as
within the religious police, and seemed to
indicate that he was willing to pursue if
not what we might call a more liberal political
path, at least one that was softer on issues
of tolerance and the importance of Islam more
generally.
All of that was undone earlier this year in
the context of the bailout package.
So in many ways, what I'm arguing is that
Saudi Arabia return to a familiar playbook,
one that was first mapped out in the late
1970s in response to an earlier moment of
domestic crisis.
So Saudi Arabia is now sort of playing a game
that it played in the early 1980s and throughout
that decade and that also produced all kinds
of pathologies and sets of political sort
of tendencies that we should be concerned
about, not the least of which was the rise
of militancy, sectarianism and all that other
stuff.
Right, so I don't agree that Saudi Arabia
was little affected.
It's true that the kingdom didn't enjoy or
experience mobilization and that Saudi citizens
haven't come to realize political rights or
opportunity, but the state has undergone a
significant transition back to one that -- to
something that resembles, you know, an earlier
moment and one that we should be concerned
about.
The second set of concerns -- and I'll deal
with this very quickly -- has to do with the
U.S.- Saudi relationship.
How should we think about Saudi Arabia and
its alliance -- or the way -- how should the
U.S. think about its approach to Saudi Arabia
in the region?
And here, too, Greg has outlined I think a
number of ways that we have historically thought
about Saudi Arabia and that seem sort of pressing
in the moment, two of which I think are transparent
and very clear.
One is on the issue of nonproliferation.
Clearly, it's not in the United States's interests
to see Saudi Arabia follow the path of Pakistan
or Iran, if Iran is in fact pursuing nuclear
weapons.
And the other is counterterrorism.
The second of the third is counterterrorism,
where I think American and Saudi interests
have very clearly aligned since at least 2003,
when Saudi Arabia was forced to deal with
its own phenomenon of domestic terrorism.
The third, though, I think, is less clear
to me, and it's less clear to me, although
it enjoys a kind of hegemonic status within
the analytical community.
And that's that the United States and Saudi
Arabia see the question of regional security
in the same terms.
Greg outlined one approach to this, and that
was countering or containing Iranian ambition
and hegemony in the region.
And it's certainly true that the U.S. and
Saudi Arabia agree that Iran has the potential
to do great harm, and that it seeks -- and
that the Saudis and the Iranians are engaged
in a balance of power struggle.
And the U.S. would like to see Iran not win
that -- not win that competition.
But there's more to security than this.
There's more to security for the Americans,
and there's more to security for the Saudis.
Greg mentioned that I've been an advocate
of sort of making sense of Saudi Arabia's
response to the Arab Spring through the lens
of counterrevolution.
I think this is a semantic difference between
us.
And I don't think -- and I think Greg sort
of not unfairly but I think mistakenly concludes
that by calling Saudi Arabia a "counterrevolutionary
power," that I necessarily attributed the
ability to accomplish those things.
Success shouldn't necessarily be conflated
with its desire to achieve a certain political
outcome.
So what is it that Saudi Arabia wants to achieve
in the Middle East?
Yes, it supported the overthrow of Qadhafi.
But much like Gates -- you know, Robert Gates
said about Libya, it was relatively easy for
the U.S. to make a decision about intervention
in Libya because it's pretty far removed from
our core area of interests.
The same is true for Saudi Arabia.
Qadhafi wasn't loved in Riyadh.
It doesn't necessarily change the balance
of power either in the Levant or in the Persian
Gulf for the Saudis to have supported his
overthrow.
So, you know, I don't necessarily agree that
just because Saudi Arabia promoted or supported
regime change there that it isn't in fact
a counterrevolutionary power.
Closer to home -- and I do think Bahrain is
a very clear example where Saudi Arabia has
been -- but even in Yemen and Syria, where
Saudi Arabia has allegedly been behind part
of the negotiations to have Saleh step down,
and it remains to be seen if he'll actually
do so or on what terms he'll actually do so
-- as well as in Syria -- my argument would
be not that the Saudis have supported a transition
of power; rather, they have specifically supported
the preservation of a certain kind of either
political status quo, as in the case of Yemen
-- the Saudis don't want to see democracy
or reform come to Yemen.
They want to see somebody like Saleh take
over there.
It's the same "Mubarakism" without Mubarak.
And in Syria, this has little to do with what
kind of political system follows the fall
of Assad.
It has everything to do with, I think, as
Greg rightly pointed out, the ability to check
Syria off the potential box of Saudi friends
in the region.
It has very little to do with the kinds of
political structures -- structures of power
-- that will take place after Assad goes away,
if he in fact does.
So if Saudi Arabia's a status quo power and
if the Arab Spring suggests to us that the
political status quo was no longer viable
and that autocratic regimes are inherently
unstable -- and maybe the Arab Spring will
hasten all of this, the unfolding of autocratic
regimes elsewhere -- I mean, this seems to
me to be not a key or an indicator of future
stability but, rather, the -- rather the sort
of permanent realization or pursuit of an
inherently unstable arrangement of regional
alliances that may only be stable for six
months to a year at a time.
That's not the kind of place that I think
the U.S. should put its political emphasis
or make its policy objectives.
The last thing I want to talk about -- with
respect to security, Greg mentioned oil and
sort of the importance of oil in Saudi Arabia's
shifting nature as an oil power.
I happen to think that when we talk about
security, historically what the U.S. has emphasized
since the mid-20th century by energy security
is that it seeks to protect the flow of oil
from the Persian Gulf.
Right?
I mean, there's a reason that when Iran threatens
to close the Straits of Hormuz, it sort of
evokes this response not only from many of
us but from policymakers that this is a terrible
thing.
And it is.
I mean, if Iran was actually interested, or
able, in closing the Straits of Hormuz, don't
get me wrong, global oil markets would be
devastated, at least in the short term.
I know it would prove problematic for the
global economy, as well as for the American
economy, in a whole host of related ways.
But is in fact Saudi Arabia's commitment when
it comes to regional energy security to making
sure that oil in sufficient quantities gets
out of the Persian Gulf and to global markets.
This has long been its claim and this has
long been our claim.
And I'll just raise this as a point of discussion
that's maybe worth following up, so that I
don't belabor it too long.
The reality is is that not only in the last
five years but since the 1970s, Saudi Arabia
has not in fact been practicing or participating
in the provision of oil in sufficient quantities
to stabilize global oil prices.
Rather, it's been engaged in the manufacture
of oil scarcity.
Resources scarcity is something that guides
much of our thinking, and I used to be a believer
in peak oil and that this was a -- this was
a resource that would quickly disappear.
I was convinced that that's -- you know, basically
through empirical evidence -- that's really
not true, and that what Saudi Arabia and many
of its oil producers engage in is a sort of
restrictive approach or a limited approach
to global oil markets in which they're looking
not for sort of stability or security in the
sense that we think about; rather, they're
thinking about the maximum price that they
can achieve in order to maintain global dependence
on oil, which means that they limit the quantity
of oil that get to the market.
And the reality is that, absent all other
factors, Saudi Arabia, Iran, Iraq, Kuwait,
the Emirates, Qatar, Oman and the other oil
producers in the region are in a much more
delicate position than the United States is
in the Persian Gulf, even though it seems
the opposite is true.
Why?
Because they have to sell their oil in order
to maintain their political systems at home.
They're under incredible scrutiny and pressure
to maintain a price structure that allows
them to maintain all of the elaborate political
systems that Greg outlined.
And in fact American militarism, the presence
of our military in significant numbers in
the Persian Gulf provides them cover to manufacture
scarcity.
It doesn't work the other way around.
We're not providing them cover to make sure
that oil gets to market in sufficient quantities;
in fact, we provide them cover to do the opposite.
So if this is true -- and I think it's open
for some discussion -- if it is true, then
what security means to us in the region is
very different from what it means to Saudi
Arabia, and it should be thought of as something
that's worth criticizing and scrutinizing,
rather than assuming what's true today might
have been true three decades ago.
I'll stop there.
>>STARES: Great.
Thanks very much, Toby, for that contrasting
assessment of Saudi Arabia.
We have about 50 minutes of -- for Q&A.
Those of you who want to ask a question, do
the usual thing; wave your placard there.
I see Judith has already offered to start.
I will try to get you in the order that you
put them up.
Those in the bleachers should wave frantically
if they want to be recognized.
And I will try to call on you.
So Judith, take it away.
>>QUESTIONER: Just a quick point to Toby.
I'm not sure I could go with the oil scarcity
theory, but I think we also need to recognize
that Saudi Arabia's in the middle of an energy
crisis of its own, which is why they're going
for alternative and nuclear.
They're using today 4 million barrels a day
for domestic purposes.
Their population doubles every 20 years.
They're going to be using 9 million within
10 years, and that means they have no income.
So you know, the question of what's going
on and how they're selling their oil I think
deserves to be examined very, very closely.
And Greg, excellent report and so on, but
I think in your presentation -- I haven't
had a chance to fully devour all of the report
yet.
You may talk about it there.
I think you can't talk about Saudi -- you
know, promoting sectarianism (Iraq ?) and
Bahrain without recognizing that between 2000
and 2008, they had very serious problems with
the U.S., the catastrophe of, I think, the
Iraq War, the unequivocal, unconditional choice
of Maliki by the U.S. and the continued support
for Maliki, who the king doesn't trust -- thinks
he lied to him and that he's an agent of Iran,
some of which may be true, some of which is
not true -- and also Bahrain.
I mean, when Bahrain blew, it seems to me
that the United States and Saudi Arabia made
really catastrophic mistakes.
I mean, that was the moment for the U.S. to
call up the king and tell him the prime minister
has to go; let the crown prince do a dialogue.
And I think the violence could have been avoided
because I think the Khalifa family has some
very, very important limitations.
They've ruined the way the government has
run.
And there are some very real issues in Bahrain
that could have been handled.
They can't now, but they could have been,
but we -- you know, we don't have a Middle
East policy.
I would say in terms of threat, of course
they're petrified.
They're so allergic to Shi'ite you can't even
mention it to the Ph.D.s.
You know, I'm sure you've had that experience,
so there's no point even to talk about it.
Iran of course scares them to death.
But I think that the biggest threat to Saudi
Arabia is demographic.
They're old guys, succession, et cetera.
They simply cannot handle the demography.
As I said, population doubles every 20 years;
seven children average per woman; 60 percent
under the age of 20; 40 percent under the
age of 13.
And even if oil is $300 a barrel, they cannot
keep them down and out and quiet by paying
them off.
So how they handle their education is the
key to the security and stability in the future.
>>STARES: All right.
I want you to digest that.
Do you want to -- (off mic) -- or do you want
to respond?
>>GAUSE: Yeah, yeah, sure.
I mean, I think this demographic issue is
fascinating because I think for years the
Saudis lied about their population, right,
and they exaggerated it, so we thought there
were more Saudis than there actually were.
Now it seems we're getting down to a relatively
reliable number.
Right?
About 30 million now, 22 million of them Saudis.
The demographics are not great.
There's no question about it.
But they probably aren't as bad as many people
think they are, because we tend to think back
to the inflated figures that they pushed up
until the '90s.
But without a doubt, there's a demographic
issue here.
How they deal with it, of course, is -- the
approach from the last oil crash of the late
'90s was we're going to let the private sector
do this.
And the Saudi private sector has become an
extremely powerful creator of jobs.
Unfortunately, all those jobs go to foreigners,
and that's part of the deal in Saudi Arabia.
Right?
Unless the Saudi government can do a political
deal with its private sector, which is a dependent
private sector but a much more sophisticated
and interesting one than in the oil boom of
the '70s, and a much more globalized one -- unless
the Saudis can get this deal done, where they
can increase the price of foreign labor and
thus increase the incentives for their own
private sector to hire Saudis, train them
-- because they're not being trained in the
schools -- and give them jobs, then I think
that that's a huge problem.
It's not that people don't realize this.
People talk about this all the time.
It's a question of political will, and it
hasn't been summoned yet.
>>JONES: But there's no mechanism.
>>GAUSE: Well, there's a mechanism.
The king could -- the mechanism in Saudi Arabia
is the king says, and it happens, right?
>>JONES: Well, no.
>>GAUSE: Except for codification of Shari'a
--
>>JONES: Which hasn't happened.
>>GAUSE: -- which he says -- and it hasn't
happened.
>>JONES: I mean, there's no pressure on the
royal family to take these steps.
I mean, I don't think there's a sense -- I
think there's a -- there's a recognition --
>>GAUSE: Everybody talks about this all the
time.
>>JONES: Well, then -- you know, then they're
not rational actors, right?
And we know this -- that because they won't
--
>>GAUSE: Well, no, they're short-term actors.
>>JONES: -- they won't very clearly sort of
undertake what's necessary.
I'm not sure education's the answer.
I mean, we're -- I mean, that's a cultural
sort of -- you know, that's offering up a
cultural explanation that if we could retrain
them in certain ways that they might find
their way forward to more serious and sort
of what might be more recognizable forms of
development and economic practice.
The reality is this is all political.
The Saudis were very calculated about how
they both structured the political/economic
system but also how people seek to siphon
rents off of it.
I mean, this is -- this is completely reasonable
behavior, given the centrality of oil.
I mean, I'm not going to speak for Greg.
But I mean, I think the Saudis are stuck.
I think they're fundamentally stuck in a dilemma
that they cannot figure a way out of.
And they don't have the political will to
do it, which means it's going to come about
spectacularly at some point.
It may not be five years from now, but eventually.
>>STARES: Michael?
>>QUESTIONER: Panelists barely touched on
the subject of succession.
Let's accept Greg's definition that the -- that
the real serious issue to talk about is the
succession to the next generation of leaders.
I'd like -- I'd be interested in the panelists'
comments on how successful that new generation
is in terms of the very complicated set of
political skills that Gregory outlined as
being essential to stability if we want to
accept that just for a moment in Saudi Arabia.
>>GAUSE: The next generation is too big to
generalize about.
I mean, there's incredibly competent people
and interesting people.
There are wastrels.
There are people who would -- who we would
consider to be radical extremists.
And there are people who would be much more
comfortable in Mayfair or in Georgetown than
they are in their own country.
It is such a diverse group that I'm very uncomfortable
in generalizing about it.
The only thing that I would say is I've never
met a single one of them -- and I've met some
of them -- who doesn't think that it's their
family's right to rule the country.
They are -- they're not political reformers
the way we would understand political reform,
it seems to me.
My bottom line on succession is that those
who talk about it don't know about it, and
those who know about it don't talk about it.
So I'll prove that I don't know about it by
talking a little bit about it.
And it seems to me that there's an untested
-- you know, that they've -- trying to institutionalize
it with this allegiance commission, the Bay'ah
committee, commission, but this is a completely
untested institution.
And the smoothest way that this would happen
is while the old guys, the remnants of the
old guys are alive, that they do a deal and
that that deal then gets ratified by this
new institution and that in that deal they
make clear that there's a number of lines
in the family that are going to continue to
have an important role.
But this is also a question of political will.
Toby talked about how they -- you know, they
don't have the political will.
If they have the political will to do this,
I think that the next generation's succession
could be smooth.
But if they keep kicking the can down the
road and then they all die, then I don't know.
I mean, it's a wide -- it's wide open at that
point.
The Saudis have been pretty good at dealing
with succession since the problems of the
late '50s and early '60s, which was very touch
and go.
Toby said 1979 as the turning point of modern
Saudi history; frankly, I think the late '50s
and early '60s was the most dangerous time
for the al-Saud family.
They were beset by regional -- real regional
enemies in Nasser's pan-Arabism.
They had a civil war going on in Yemen from
the early '60s.
And they were profoundly split domestically.
And they had as much opposition I think domestically,
and perhaps even at a more elite level, than
they have now.
And, you know, they go through that through
luck.
And if this generation remembers that dicey
time, the coming generation, maybe they'll
be able to work it out.
But I don't make any predictions on that.
>>STARES: Toby, anything you want to add on
-- OK.
I think -- (name inaudible) -- and then Elise.
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Well, thank you to both of our presenters,
and thank you to Paul for convening such a
stimulating and really excellent panel here.
It seems that since the Arab uprisings began,
we've seen a different type of Saudi foreign
policy if -- in style if not in substance.
The objectives may be status quo.
They may be counterrevolutionary.
But at least it seems to be a style of activism
that we've not seen before -- be it the approach
it took vis-a-vis Qadhafi, the approach it
took in Bahrain, the approach it's taken elsewhere
in calling for the U.N. to intervene in various
conflicts.
One, is this in fact a phenomenon, or is this
just an ahistorical observation?
And if indeed it is true, is this a function
and a reaction to a perceived absence of American
activism and role?
Or how do you explain it, if in fact -- an
accurate description of reality?
>>GAUSE: Yeah, you know, I think that this
activism actually predates the Arab Spring.
It's just they've failed on most of their
initiatives.
I mean, I think that there are three areas
where -- once the king decided -- '07 -- '06,
'07 that he couldn't do any deals with the
Iranians and they were not to be trusted,
I think he made three initiatives, all of
which failed, right, all aimed at rolling
back Iranian influence in the Arab world.
One was in Iraq -- very strong support for
Allawi.
He backed Allawi in '05 but strong support
for Allawi.
The second was Lebanon -- strong support for
Hariri in March 14, and in Palestine trying
to bring Hamas and Fatah together in an effort
to, you know, cut off this Iranian-Hamas developing
relationship.
He failed on every one of those.
You know, one of the jokes I tell is that,
you know, you can understand why the Saudis
are so reluctant about democracy.
I mean, you know, they back Allawi.
He wins the elections, gets the most seats,
doesn't become prime minister.
They back March 14.
It wins the election.
Hezbollah runs the government.
Of course they don't think democracy works.
When they pay for democracy and their guys
win, they don't get to rule.
So I think that the Saudis have been more
active, but they've failed.
They've failed.
And one of the reasons they played up the
Houthis in Yemen so much, it seemed to be,
is because they thought that they needed a
victory.
You know, they're going to make this bunch
of guys in Yemen into clients of Iran.
You know, they use Iranian revolutionary rhetoric,
but there's no great evidence that the Houthis
are clients of Iran.
So they make them into clients of Iran and
they go pound them.
"We won one."
And I think that that was a large impetus
behind the publicity that the Saudis gave
to the Houthis.
So I don't see this activism now -- in fact,
I see them in the Arab Spring as being incredibly
discombobulated.
Right?
They weren't at the front on Libya; they were
in the back, and they came along.
It took them months to decide that Bashar
was not their guy.
You know, this innate desire for nothing to
change really was not -- they were not well-suited
to deal with the events of 2011 because so
much was changing everywhere.
I think the only new thing that we see in
2011 -- you know, and Toby and I here disagree.
Right?
The only new thing we see is a willingness
to use Saudi forces beyond their borders to
protect regimes that they think are key to
them.
Now, this isn't the first time Saudi troops
have been in Bahrain.
Right?
In the mid-'90s --
>>JONES: '96.
>>GAUSE: Right, when the GCC summit -- that
first -- that intifada -- the mid-'90s intifada
started in Bahrain.
The Saudis sent troops into Bahrain as well.
Right?
But the very public way with which it was
done, they made no secret about it.
They were not apologetic about it.
That is the only new thing that I see.
>>JONES: Yeah.
No, I do think that sort of the scope or the
breadth of Saudi activism is new; I mean,
moving on multiple fronts at one time.
And I'll address, Rob, the sort of second
part of your question, and that is: How does
this -- what does this tell us about what
the Saudis think about the U.S.?
I think the Saudis are in a difficult position.
I think the way they think about this is that
they have a complicated place, that historically
they believe they've had a special relationship.
But since 2001 and, arguably, from the Clinton
administration, they felt like it's been a
relationship under pressure in various ways.
So they've been put in a position where they
have to balance that uncertainty with a kind
of desperate sense that they want to preserve
it as best as possible.
The Chinese aren't a reasonable alternative
to the U.S.
The Chinese can't project kind of military
power, the political will to do the sorts
of things that the U.S. has historically been
willing to do.
But at the same time, as Judith pointed out,
the U.S. doesn't have a Middle East policy.
We don't have a clear approach.
We don't know what our priorities are, and
Andrew has said the same thing in multiple
settings, right, that you know, it's kind
of ad hoc; it's convoluted.
Are we committed to democracy at this point,
or are we a status quo power ourselves?
Is Iran going to shape our policy, or it is
going to be some combination of things?
I think the Saudis understand very clearly,
perhaps better than most, the uncertainty
that characterizes the American position.
And that activism that I think you've correctly
identified -- and I think Greg's right, too;
it has its roots elsewhere but -- is partly
a reflection of a power in the Middle East
that's got a lot of resources.
It's got a lot of money, even if it's convoluted,
to be able to attempt to shape outcomes.
Again, I wouldn't attribute to the Saudis
necessarily a level of success that they've
been effective, but I think they're trying.
>>STARES: OK, Elise and the Michelle (sp).
>>QUESTIONER: Thanks so much, both of you,
for this really interesting discussion.
And Greg, I really enjoyed the report.
A just quick follow-up on the succession issue,
and then I -- a question about the Salafists.
On the succession issue, I mean, I don't want
to call King Abdullah a reformer, but when
I -- when I use --
>>GAUSE: Not when you're sitting next to Toby
Jones, you don't, no.
>>QUESTIONER: Exactly.
But when I say that, you know, I think if
there was any anybody that thought that King
Abdullah on the scales tipped more towards
reform than not -- and I think the death of
the crown prince -- a lot of people were very
concerned that -- about Prince Nayef.
And does that take Saudi Arabia -- you know,
instead of begrudgingly going along with small
reforms, are we going to see under -- as we
move towards succession, are we moving even
farther away from that?
Or do you think that the new leadership eventually
will have to begrudgingly accept some more
freedoms for the people?
And then on the Salafists, I was wondering
if you could touch upon Saudi funding for
some of these groups, political groups, throughout
the region.
And does that -- does the rise of more Islamic
parties help Saudi consolidate its leadership
position in the region?
Or are we seeing in the region -- as we've
seen Qatar and Turkey take greater leadership
roles in the region, is it too late for that?
>>JONES: Let me just offer this up: My understanding
of the Saudi role in the -- in terms of who
it's supporting and who it's not supporting,
they're not supporting the Salafis or the
Islamists at all.
The Saudis are --
>>QUESTIONER: I was wondering.
I thought maybe they were giving --
>>GAUSE: I'm sure that they raise -- I'm sure
plenty of these Salafists -- everybody in
Egypt --
>>QUESTIONER: A lot of people -- a lot of
people are wondering where the money is coming
from.
>>GAUSE: Everybody in Egypt says all this
money for the Salafists come from Saudi.
They never have any evidence.
>>JONES: But state funding went to SCAF.
>>GAUSE: Yeah, state funding is a different
story and not as -- but not as much as they
promised.
>>JONES: But the Saudis are --
>>GAUSE: They promised ($)4 billion and they
probably haven't even given a billion.
>>JONES: Right, well, it's only a billion.
(Laughter.)
The Saudis have been very clear, I mean, in
spite of Nayef's comments that we will maintain
our commitment to Salifism -- which, by the
way, is a new thing.
The Saudis haven't always called it Salifism
--
>>GAUSE: Right.
>>JONES: -- so this is kind of an innovation.
The kingdom's position, historically, on the
Islamists, while they've cultivated relationships
with some sectors of it, have been deeply
nervous about the power of Islam and the Muslim
Brotherhood in particular.
And that has to do with their own domestic
experience, as well as events in the region.
I think they're -- you know, the obvious thing
might be to say in Egypt, with the success
of the Islamists in the parliamentary elections,
is that the Saudis are pleased.
I think the Saudis are in fact very anxious
and would like to see SCAF ultimately hold
onto power and not give up.
>>GAUSE: Yeah, I have no doubt that the Salafists
have networks into Saudi Arabia and raise
money there.
How could they not.
Right?
There are all sorts of sympathetic people
in Saudi Arabia.
I get no indication that it's a government
policy to back the Salafists.
And I think that -- I agree with Toby here;
I think that the Saudis are profoundly nervous
about this, because if you get the whole -- if
you get the Salafist movement basically saying,
"Yeah, democratic politics all good," that's
troublesome to them in a way that goes beyond
the tactical.
So, yeah, I think that, you know, the fact
that the Salafis in Egypt sometimes run up
the Saudi flag at their rallies and all, it
must -- the king must see that on TV and go,
"Good" -- (laughs) -- you know, but I don't
think that they're banking on the Salafists
to be their lever in Egypt.
And the Brothers, I mean, Nayef has publicly,
on more than one occasion, said the brothers
are the cause of everything bad that's happened
in the Middle East.
So he -- he doesn't like them at all.
So the thing with the brothers is even more
complicated, in terms of how the Saudis view
this.
>>JONES: In fact, the most powerful potential
opposition force in Saudi Arabia is the Saudi
analog to the Egyptian Muslim Brothers.
>>GAUSE: Really?
You think so?
>>JONES: Well, I mean, well --
>>GAUSE: I don't think so.
>>JONES: You don't think that the sahwa still
has the potential capacity to mobilize?
>>GAUSE: I mean, I think the sahwa only can
do that.
This word, sahwa, awakening, is something
that gets thrown around in the Middle East
all the time.
Now, the Arab Spring is the sahwa.
Right?
And then there is the sahwa in Iraq, right,
where the Sunnis --
>>JONES: Should've trademarked --
>>GAUSE: -- somebody should've -- but the
sahwa in Saudi Arabia, which Toby has written
about, and the best book on it is Stephane
Lacroix's book, was this kind of Muslim Brotherhood-influenced
but also Salafi-influenced bunch in the '80s
who come up and start to give a political
critique of the regime.
And in the '90s, after the Gulf War, they
come into their own as very critical of the
regime.
After 9/11, all of these guys come back and
rally to the regime and become big supporters
of the regime.
Right?
I would argue because they saw al-Saud rule
under pressure.
Right?
If there was going to be some international
reaction to 9/11 against Saudi rule, they
were going to be with the regime, because
in the end, these Salafists cannot -- you
know, the reason they're not bin Laden is
that none of these guys can imagine a Salafi
state in Arabia that is not ruled by the al-Saud.
And I think that that's why I don't think
of them as the biggest problem for the Saudis.
On the succession thing, I'll demonstrate
my ignorance even more by talking more about
this.
(Laughter.)
Look, Nayef has been the chief of police for
38 years, right?
Thirty-three years, something in there.
And when you're the chief of police for that
long, you develop a certain view of politics,
I think.
We're not going to see any political reform
the way we would understand political reform,
in terms of voting, in terms of legislatures.
I don't think we're going to see that under
Nayef.
On the other hand, I'm very reluctant to say
that he's going to roll back the small but
real social changes that Abdullah has allowed,
particularly on the issue of women.
These guys don't like to repudiate their predecessors.
I mean, they do have that sense of family
cohesion and we've got to stick together.
You know, even after King Saud was bounced,
they named the airport and the university
and all sorts of things -- Faisal named all
those things after him.
Right?
And so I would be reluctant to say that Nayef
is, you know, the opposite of Abdullah.
But I don't think that Nayef is a political
reformer, but I don't think Abdullah is a
political reformer.
I do think that a long-term consequence of
the events of 2011 are that eventually Saudi
Arabia is going to have an elected legislature.
I think that the political trends regionally
are moving in that direction.
I think that the political ideological trends
in Saudi Arabia are moving in that direction.
I think that in the next generation, there
will be more acceptance of that notion.
I think it will be -- and then it will be
problematic, just like the legislature in
Kuwait is problematic, just like the legislature
in other of these monarchies can be problematic
for the monarch.
But I think -- and this is a change in my
view.
Before 2011, I didn't think the Saudis would
go that way at all, but now I think they probably
will, just not under Nayef.
>>STARES: OK.
Michele Dunne?
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Elise actually asked my question about the
Salafis, but I just wanted to add a note on
something else.
Greg, you were mentioning that the failure
of the opposition, or the inability of the
opposition in Saudi Arabia to unite being
one of the reasons why you weren't expecting
-- or why you think it's stable.
And that's empirically true, that they failed
to unite.
But I just wanted to point out that in Tunisia
and Egypt, this happened very quickly.
You know, all of a sudden we're -- you know,
these disparate opposition forces had tried
and failed and they looked weak and they looked
feckless and, you know, all that kind of thing.
And then, just, you know, overnight or over
the course of days and weeks, it happened.
So it's not -- again, as Toby said, I think,
you know, the fact that it didn't happen in
the past -- you know, it won't.
>>GAUSE: You're right.
And I'm one of those people who was very enamored
of the literature on the stability of Arab
authoritarianism.
And so I've had to do a rethink all this past
year about, you know, what we got wrong on
that literature.
I think that literature is still very valuable
for explaining why these regimes lasted as
long as they did, but we certainly missed
things that were happening.
And there are the hints of that in Saudi Arabia,
of people trying to cross ideological and
sectarian lines to talk to each other.
And, you know, occasionally even issuing,
you know, little proclamations.
But to me, here -- to me, for Saudi Arabia
here was the moment that crystallized the
fact that nothing was going to happen: As
Ben Ali fell -- right after Ben Ali fell and
as Egyptians were starting the Tahrir Square
revolt, there was a big flood in Jeddah, killed
10, 12 people.
This is on top of a flood a couple years before,
which killed over 100 people, after which,
the king himself said, this will not happen
again; we will make sure that this does not
happen again.
And then it happened again.
I said, "Wow, if there's ever a time when
people should come into the streets in Jeddah,
the ones that aren't flooded anyway, this
is it."
Ben Ali, down -- the Egyptians, in the streets
and everyone in Saudi Arabia watching them.
And here, the regime has failed in a promise
that should have been easy for them to keep,
because it's just spending money getting the
engineering right and, you know, stopping
this.
And they didn't do it.
Nothing happened.
I was floored.
I was flabbergasted.
I thought this was a moment that something
might happen in Saudi Arabia.
Nothing happened.
>>JONES: Well, I think, you know, Egypt happened
spontaneously.
I think that's right.
But there was also -- there were forces on
this sort of -- it was a civil society in
Egypt that could mobilize different sectors.
Maybe they hadn't previously thought of one
another as kind of being like-minded, at least
on the question of revolution or political
change, but nevertheless had the capacity
to organize.
Saudi Arabia doesn't historically have the
same kind of vibrant -- there's not the ability
or the space for Saudis to come together.
But I think we're seeing those institutions
and organizational efforts begin to materialize.
And the Jeddah floods might be the impetus
in one place, but the prospects are that it's
going to have to take some time before all
of this can mature or be realized in a meaningful
way.
And let's face it, the Saudis also learned,
like others in the region did, from the Egyptian
example in particular, about how to -- at
least how to attempt to preempt it from happening
quickly.
I think the jury's still out.
I don't think the Arab Spring's over, by any
means.
You know, I'm not predicting that Saudi Arabia
in the next six months is going to have a
revolutionary moment.
But I wouldn't say it's impossible either.
>>STARES: Doug and then Mark.
>>QUESTIONER: With respect to a relationship
between Saudi Arabia and Iraq, how much of
it is personal and how much political?
Is there some type of policy that Iraq could
realistically do?
I mean, Maliki's figured out he doesn't have
to share power with the Sunnis and he's not
going to, not for a generation.
I think that's pretty clear.
Is there something else he could do, you know,
vis-a-vis reaching out to the Saudis or taking
some firmer stand against Iran?
And is that just -- with the current regime,
does that calculus change three, five years
from now?
>>JONES: I just had a piece come out at a
USIP edited volume, with Scott Lasensky and
Phebe Marr and others, that argues that the
Saudis approach this in a couple of ways,
the Iraq dilemma for them.
One is certainly personal and it has to do
with the way Maliki talked about Iran and
about Saudi power in the region.
And certainly for Abdullah, I think that's
the case.
But I think there are other -- there are at
least two other political calculations, one
big one, and that is that the Saudis are uncertain
about whether the U.S. is going to abandon
them in the region.
And the Saudis, as late as last year, believed
that the U.S. would maintain some kind of
political-military commitment to Iraq and
wanted it to do so.
All right, they don't want the Americans to
leave Iraq.
They don't want -- well, too late.
>>GAUSE: They didn't want us to go in.
They didn't want us to leave.
>>JONES: Right, so part of this was also an
attempt to wedge the Americans to maintain
sort of an ongoing commitment to Iraq, that
if you leave, this could become a conflagration
point.
And the other part of that is is that the
Saudis also, I think, calculated wrongly that
if they were unwilling to work with the Americans
or think constructively about how to build
a better relationship, they might have some
leverage over the U.S. on Palestine.
And that's -- if the Arab Spring didn't obviate
that, then it was never going to happen anyway.
Right?
So I think that's also part of what the Saudis
were thinking.
>>GAUSE: Yeah, I mean, I think that -- this
is a guess on my part, but Abdullah has been
pretty flexible on all sorts of things.
But on this one he seems to have really dug
in his heels.
And I don't -- I just don't think that -- I
mean, any new Saudi initiative toward Iraq
I think is going to depend on a change in
leadership at the top.
I think there are people in Saudi who recognize
that their approach to Iraq is self-defeating,
that it is, in effect, leaving the field open
to Iran.
And I think that that's an argument that is
not publicly articulated in Saudi Arabia,
but it is articulated at high enough levels
that perhaps there might be a rethink after
the current king goes.
>>STARES: Mark Finley?
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
The sentiment expressed throughout the conversation,
by both the speakers and the guests, about
-- you know, for a variety of demographic
and social reasons, you know, whatever the
status quo is, you know, the logic is inexorable
that, you know, the price of oil needed to
sustain it goes higher.
Obviously the price of oil can't go higher
forever, and so my question is -- at some
point the regime has to deal with coping mechanisms.
And here's my question: Among the array of
coping mechanisms that I can think of, cutting
subsidies, pursuing -- somebody mentioned
nuclear power, other forms of energy, raising
production capacity, inviting in foreign investment
-- which of these coping mechanisms is likely
to be most -- least unattractive to the Saudi
body politic?
>>JONES: Least --
>>GAUSE: Least unattractive?
Nuclear power.
>>JONES: That's it.
>>GAUSE: Build as many plants as you want.
>>JONES: Yeah, I mean, I think it's the only
route that would basically -- it would not
affect Saudi citizens in any meaningful way.
>>GAUSE: Look, there are other things that
can be done.
This is not -- see, this is where I think
Toby and I differ.
I don't think this is a fragile regime.
I think that this regime could in fact reduce
subsidies, especially now in a time of, you
know, pretty good economic time.
I mean, with all the unemployment issues and
all, this is not a bad economic time in Saudi
Arabia.
They could do it.
They just -- they have to summon the political
will.
And there are ways to do it that can lessen
its impact on those who would be most affected.
All right?
And then there are some technical fixes that
have to be done.
Right?
There are some -- these aren't sexy and they
aren't political, but you know, aging infrastructure
uses more energy than new infrastructure.
And, you know, you can get more natural gas
if you actually -- I mean, I know they drill
dry holes and all, but you can presumably
get more natural gas in Saudi Arabia and stop
burning so much oil to generate electricity.
But no, the easiest thing is just build all
those nuclear power plants.
But they're slow off the dime on that.
I think that they can deal with the subsidy
issue and it won't shake the regime.
But this would be a good time to do it, frankly.
>>JONES: Well, but the only time they can
sort of end the sort of -- what is really
a systematic and structural sweeping subsidy
regime that wouldn't affect people is to dip
into their savings.
>>GAUSE: They've got plenty right now.
>>JONES: And they've got plenty right now,
but you said yourself that there's, you know,
the oil market may not bear $110 a barrel
oil for the foreseeable future.
I mean, that brings into play alternative
energies, whether it's shale oil or whether
it's natural gas or whether it's other things,
that may make the Saudis no longer competitive.
It may render irrelevant the question of spare
capacity.
And then the Saudis really lose their ability
to manage.
So if they think they can end subsidies, let
them try.
I think it unleashes all kinds of things that
would be problematic for them at home, as
well as their place in the global economy.
In fact, I think we should advocate for that
and then see what happens.
(Laughter.)
>>GAUSE: You and I can get behind this policy,
but for different reasons.
>>STARES: (Off mic.)
>>QUESTIONER: Thank you.
Thank you both for your presentation and given
the Saudis' interest in the status quo, and
certainly stability in the region, it was
easy to understand their concern with the
Mubarak fall, maybe also with Qadhafi, given
kind of the peripheral of Libya and Saudi
Arabia.
I'd be interested in hearing more about how
you think they are looking at Syria.
Bashar al-Assad may not be a very well-loved
entity in Riyadh, but still, the Syria question
--
>>GAUSE: That's an understatement.
>>QUESTIONER: -- is a lot more complex in
terms of what could happen.
So they're watching the (off mic) in Egypt
or al-Nahda, in Tunisia.
But what could happen in Syria would be very
different.
And the other thing I was interested in to
hear your comments on, the dynamics between
Saudi Arabia and Qatar, given the rising role
of Doha in dealing with issues like Syria
and Libya and others.
And how are those two playing, as they see
their role in regional politics?
>>GAUSE: Well, okay, I'll take the first swing,
Ambassador.
Syria: I think that if the Saudi media is
any indication of official thinking, and I
think given the uniformity in which -- with
which I see the Saudi media dealing with Syria,
I think it probably is -- they've washed their
hands of Bashar al-Assad.
I mean, the worst things are said about him
every day, even in the most mainstream, you
know, kind of -- the most responsible Saudi
media, the worst things are said about Bashar
al-Assad.
And it seems to me that, despite the uncertainties
of his fall, the elites have basically come
to the conclusion that they're better off
without him than with him.
And I think that this is largely driven by
their view of their regional competition with
Iran.
Will there be problems in reconstructing?
Obviously.
I think the Saudis feel that they have levers
that they can exercise.
>>JONES: But if they have a plan --
>>GAUSE: We don't see it.
>>JONES: -- for a post-Assad Syria, what's
it look like?
Who takes power?
>>GAUSE: Who does have a plan?
>>JONES: And if --
>>GAUSE: Nobody has a plan for -- not even
the Syrian opposition has a plan for --
>>QUESTIONER: Not even the opposition.
>>GAUSE: -- has a plan for a post-Assad Syria.
>>JONES: Right, so I mean, what is the end
game in Syria for the Saudis and the --
>>GAUSE: The end game is to get the damn Shi'ites
out and cut the Iranians down to size, right?
>>JONES: So it's just to replace Assad with
a group of elites that are more favorable
to the Saudis.
At least that seems --
>>QUESTIONER: And are more Sunni.
>>JONES: -- and you figure out who that is,
I suppose.
>>GAUSE: I mean, that could be generated through
elections.
That could be generated any number of ways.
I think that the Saudis are realistic enough
to know that given what's happened this year,
it would be very, very hard anywhere to have
a change of regime that doesn't have at least
some kind of an election.
Now, you know, they can try to manipulate
it and things like that, but, I mean, I don't
think that they're powerful enough to prevent
that and I think that they realize that they've
got to swim with this tide.
Maybe the tide changes after a while, but
this is a tide they have to swim with.
>>STARES: What is their pre-Assad plan?
That's what I'm more interested in, rather
than the post one?
We jumped over a major event here.
>>GAUSE: Oh, you mean the fall of the regime?
>>STARES: What do they do now?
Yeah, what do --
>>GAUSE: I don't think anybody has any bright
ideas.
I think they do more of the same.
They're going to ask us, "What are you going
to do about this?"
>>JONES: There is some symbolic capital that's
earned by supporting, right, the fall of a
quasi-unpopular -- I don't know, is Assad
unpopular at home?
>>GAUSE: Seems to be unpopular in certain
circles.
>>JONES: Syria is certainly divided, I think,
on the viability of Assad going forward, right?
But the Saudis also, I think, generate some
symbolic capital outside of Syria by saying
that they support and that they're not a counterrevolutionary
force, especially at home.
There's also -- I mean, the most cynical side
of me says that the Saudis actually benefit
a great deal by making sure that if there's
going to be crisis in the region that it happens
somewhere else.
If they're seen to be involved and attempting
to manage things, then that maybe pays dividends.
But if you're talking about the Saudis being
ineffective, I mean, this would be a terrible
way to approach foreign policy, right?
>>GAUSE: Do you think the Saudis are powerful
enough that they can cause uprisings in Syria?
>>JONES: No.
But there were already uprisings in Syria.
>>GAUSE: Yeah.
>>JONES: So you throw the weight of the Arab
League behind it and for Syrian opposition
forces, that's a pretty powerful indication
of what's possible, if you sustain the fight.
Now ultimately, the Arab League has made,
you know, very clear gestures that the next
stop is the U.N. Security Council.
>>GAUSE: Look, I think that it's useful to
talk about how the Saudis approach Syria,
but it's not nearly as important as how some
other countries approach Syria.
And Turkey is a lot more important than Saudi
Arabia on the immediate question of where
this uprising goes and where this regime goes.
>>JONES: I think the question of Qatar's role
has gotten a lot of attention.
>>GAUSE: Too much.
>>JONES: And perhaps there is -- you know,
historically there's been a rivalry.
But it's interesting that Qatar hasn't been
particularly assertive -- (inaudible) -- right,
close to the Saudi hegemonic heartland.
You don't see a --
>>GAUSE: Absolutely silent on --
>>JONES: Qatar's not pushing on issues that
the Saudis really think are a point of emphasis,
and I don't think they would.
I think the Saudis are content to let them
-- in fact, I don't think Saudi has all that
-- or historically has had all that much influence
in Yemen.
And if the Saudis believe that the Qataris
could come in and negotiate some kind of compromised
transition of power, more -- the Saudis can't
do it.
You know, but I don't --
>>GAUSE: I disagree about Yemen.
>>STARES: Yeah, I do, too.
>>GAUSE: I think the Saudis have had lots
of power in Yemen.
But I wrote a book about that, so I have a
stake in it.
(Laughter.)
Look, Qatari foreign policy is a vanity project
by a couple of guys who are -- who want to
play a big role in the world.
And thus, I find it very difficult to analyze
it.
(Laughter.)
I mean, it's not based upon some kind of state
interest.
Right?
It's based on a splash.
And more power to them.
And many of the things they've done, including
Al-Jazeera, have been extremely positive for
the region.
But it's an irritant sometimes to the Saudis,
but I don't think it's anything more than
an irritant.
I think we all spend too much time talking
about it.
I don't think it's that important.
>>STARES: OK.
We're coming to the end.
(Arnold ?), you have the last question.
>>QUESTIONER: Yeah, I wonder if you could
quickly address the problem of succession
after Prince Nayef.
How many of the Sudairi Seven are left, and
does that line still hold?
>>GAUSE: Yeah, Prince Salman, who is now defense
minister, long-time governor of Riyadh, one
of the full brothers.
You know, if I were a betting man, I would
put him next.
There's -- Simon, help me.
Prince Ahmed at interior --
>>MR.
: Abdul Rahman.
>>GAUSE: There's Abdul Rahman at interior,
right?
Deputy minister of interior?
>>MR.
: (Off mic.)
>>GAUSE: Yeah, Ahmad at interior, right?
Because he's the only one, other than Salman,
who has a government job, right?
>>MR.
: Yeah.
>>GAUSE: I mean, I think it's interesting
that Salman has moved to the defense ministry,
you know, because now he can say, having been
governor of Riyadh, which is one of the most
important positions in the kingdom, for a
long, long, long, long time, he's now a member
of the Cabinet.
He's dealing with foreign policy.
In many ways, one could see this almost as
a grooming.
But the internal dynamics of this are opaque
to me and the actuarial tables are -- do not
give us good indication as to how this line
will go.
>>JONES: I think there's two -- and I think
this is cross-generational.
I think there's two things that are fundamentally
true about the royal family.
One is that they're not ideological.
They're pragmatists.
Right?
And the second is that they are primarily,
overwhelmingly, in total agreement, concerned
with self-preservation.
>>GAUSE: Those are two points or one?
(Laughter.)
>>JONES: Those are two.
>>GAUSE: Oh, OK.
>>JONES: Right.
So they're not ideological, although they'll
play ideology.
Right?
And they'll use it for their purposes.
And they're interested in preserving their
power and their privilege.
And, you know, that's incentive for people
to sort of stick together.
>>STARES: Okay.
Well, this has been a fascinating discussion.
I've certainly learned a lot from it.
I want to thank you all for coming here today.
(Applause.)
And please thank our (president ?).